OK.
Let's now go to the sort of third piece of
this pie, which is Trump is losing in the
polls and Trump is getting more desperate.
And what if Trump doesn't accept the results?
Now, let's actually explore what could happen
that would give Trump a win.
And there's two sides to this.
There's the election tampering side and there's
the policy success side.
Now, I'm going to be completely transparent
with you here.
I think it is all but too late for Trump to
do anything on the policy side.
The three major issues for voters as as a
per a new poll that we looked at earlier this
week, the three major issues facing voters
right now are, according to voters, corona
virus number one, the economy and unemployment.
Number two, which is very much related to
Corona virus.
And George Floyd, police race relations.
Number three, those three are very bad for
Donald Trump.
Economy is the best for Trump, although he's
now even to underwater on economy.
So what can Trump actually do?
That is just doing stuff politically to get
support back.
Another stimulus, which is now in the works,
certainly could help in terms of, you know,
a vaccine if a vaccine is finalized and goes
wide spread before November.
It will have nothing to do with Trump.
I mean, literally nothing.
But Trump will try to take credit for it and
maybe some people would be convinced by that.
The reality is the way things are going.
Best case scenario is there's some early doses
for health care workers in the fall and it
may be after the November election anyway.
Not totally clear if some super effective
treatment is found.
Trump could try to take credit for that if
through no fault of Donald Trump's corona
virus improves and the economy improves.
Trump can certainly try to take credit.
He will claim credit and maybe it will help
him to some degree.
But I think you see the theme, which is we're
barely more than three months out and the
failures have compounded and been so outrageous
that we essentially need miracles.
I say, you know, if Trump personally cures
cancer and, you know, cancer is so many different
things.
If Trump cures all cancers between now and
November.
OK, but on the issues, there's really a limited
window for Donald Trump to be able to do anything.
Now, in terms of dirty tricks, there's a lot.
What if William Barr announces an investigation,
maybe into Joe Biden, maybe into Hunter?
Biden in October might not even work at this
point.
I don't know that people will fall for it.
People may see it as once again, like the
Hillary Clinton thing all over again, but
that might help Trump.
There are at this point, people willing to
essentially crawl over a broken glass to vote
trump out.
Not everybody, of course, but there is a high
level of motivation.
I don't even know if announcing an investigation
would work.
Could Trump engineer some kind of backroom
peace deal with somebody then touted as a
victory, the grand deal with China, a grand
deal with North Korea?
That's believable.
Or the Taliban?
Maybe.
I just don't know.
You know, we talk about domestic politics
is what works.
And right now people are dealing with the
virus and the economic fallout.
I just don't know that it would be enough
to change opinion.
So to be perfectly honest, and this is why
it gets very as I said earlier this week,
a desperate Trump is a dangerous Trump.
Trump's best path to victory right now is
suppressing the vote and trying to rig it
in his favor, which is why we have to be so
vigilant on that game.
We have to stop the voter roll purges.
We have to stop closures of voting places.
We have to prevent these paramilitaries from
continuing to be in cities until November
and being used to intimidate voters out of
voting.
That's Trump's best bet right now.
I think he probably knows it.
And that's why he's talking about vote by
mail and violence in cities, because he's
essentially giving up on all these other things.
That is why we have to remain focused and
prevent him from using that in order to win
this election.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Remember that you can get the daily audio
podcast every single day for free on any of
your favorite podcasting platforms.
If you're an AI tunes gal or a Spotify guy
or whatever.
It's widely available.
Make sure you're getting the podcast daily.
And we will see you on the